oz is running against john fetterman dr
oz joins us tonight doctor thanks so
much for coming on
um this is one of those races that i'm
not sure people are paying attention to
but the deeper you look into this guy
the more shocking it is that he's
running for public office how is this
happening do you think
well let me just give you a few examples
and i'll give you my diagnosis
he puts himself above others and the law
he does it continuously it's what he's
done throughout his career for example
he's back massive middle class tax sites
but these tax hikes don't affect him
because he's not paid his taxes 67 times
think about that you want middle class
tax hikes but you're not paying your own
67 times he carries away i'm sorry let
me just stop you there i didn't know
that so this is a guy who was supported
by his parents until he was 49 years old
he's a rich kid 49 years old he's taking
money from his parents and he hasn't
paid his taxes how does that work how is
that allowed
it's stunning to me he had a non-profit
and he also has some properties he owns
but he's got tax liens he ignores them
he said they fell through the cracks
but it gets worse than this you know the
hypocrisy runs deep he cares about
criminals over the innocent it seems you
know one-third of all prisoners in
pennsylvania he says should be released
he's argued to release convicted
murderers serving life sentences right
over the objections of the families and
others on the parole board meanwhile the
philadelphia murder rate is the highest
it has ever been you know debates that
we've been talking about are important
because he's got to be able to defend
his radical left positions but he's been
dodging them since july and the
washington post just put out an op-ed
piece saying i think what everyone
should be arguing which is for democracy
to survive you've got to have debates
you've got to answer questions and so
he's got to agree they argue for
multiple debates starting immediately to
prove his ability to serve and here's
what i think is happening to the
diagnosis i think liberals are trying to
bury the truth they have poured money
into pennsylvania manufacturing a
candidate and if you're worried about
that go to dr oz.com and help me out
because what they're trying to do is is
hide what's really going on to
manufacture somebody that seems
appealing but way outside the boundaries
of the values of pennsylvania and is
cognitively impaired i mean i'm not
being mean but it's not you know i'm not
mocking the guy for having a stroke but
we're all going to have to live under
him if he makes it to the senate we know
what happens when you elect someone
who's cognitively impaired we're living
under it now
this guy am i understanding this trick
he wants to boot the debate until after
all the early voting has basically been
conducted is that is that his
plan he has not agreed to a debate
actually a debate agreement means you
have a date a time a location a
moderator that's not what's happening
here he's not agreed to a debate and
here's what i've been challenging him on
i'm saying listen either you're healthy
enough to debate because your team keeps
saying you're healthy
and you want to hide these radical ideas
you've been thrown out there on twitter
which you can't do right or you're lying
about your health either way we need to
know the truth but there's no way for
voters in pennsylvania to understand
what this man stands for because he's
not been able to defend these positions
by the way i can keep going he wants
open borders and to legalize all drugs
meanwhile we've got the biggest open air
drug market ever in philadelphia swaths
of the city consumed by zombies with
needles hanging out of their bodies the
highest fentanyl death rates ever in
philadelphia and pennsylvania is number
three in the country for fentanyl deaths
people are crying to me wherever i go
and speaking of going i can't paint a
lot i've been to 200 places around
pennsylvania over the summer john
federman to my knowledge maybe half a
dozen spoken for a total of 25 minutes
or so i mean he just hasn't answered
questions from the media from the voters
or from me so it's not just the debate
he's got to get out and start defending
himself and he's not doing it he's
hiding it's
another decadent rich kid pushing crime
and drugs and refusing to defend his
positions this is not democracy um and i
appreciate you're calling it out dr oz
thank you very much for joining us
tonight
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight